this public order situation so over 50
petrol bombs some of the police two cars
hijacked and set on fire and then
unfortunately at eleven o'clock last
night a gunman appeared and fired a
number of shots towards a place on a
young woman lighter McKee 29 years old
was wounded she was taken away from the
scene little police lounge over shortly
Galvan Hospital but unfortunately she
has died therefore we have no launched a
murder inquiry here in the city we
believe this to be a terrorist act we
believe it's been carried out by violent
different Republicans our assessment at
this time would be that the new IRA are
most likely to be the ones behind us and
that forms our primary line of enquiry
can I say also want to pass my deepest
sympathies to the family of Miss McKee
this is a horrendous act it's
unnecessary it's uncalled for
it's totally unjustified but not only is
it the murder of a young woman it's an
attack again upon the people of this
city I stood here in January and we
talked about the bomb on the act of
violence against this city and yet again
we see another act of violence in this
city that has had horrendous
consequences which will affect people
for many many many years I would appeal
the people particularly in this Easter
weekend to stay calm I would appeal to
people who are intent and violence to
draw back I would appeal to people who
have influence to use your influence to
make sure that this is a peaceful
weekend not only this weekend but also
going forward in this city these acts of
violence are bringing nothing to this
city all they're doing is bringing
misery to one family but also
particularly to this city and also to
our broader province if people have
information I would appeal to you also
to bring it forward you can ring
Crimestoppers we can ring 101 ask for
the police here on Road we need people
who saw this happen to come forward
we're also putting on a portal for
people to upload videos that they may
have taken and I know a lot of this is
already circulating on social media but
again I would ask people to be sensitive
to the family someone has lost their
life and the last thing that family
needs is to see that played over and
over again so what ask people if you
have videos to show sensitivity and
either not show them or share them with
the police so we can use them and our
murder inquiry to try and track down the
people who have committed this
horrendous crime
the level of okay I believe that this
was orchestrated but clearly it is
reckless orchestrated to the point that
they just want to have violence and want
to primarily at this occasion to attack
police but the bringing of a firearm out
and firing at Dyna Street in a
residential area where they knew lots of
people were standing about as a
calculator than callous act and can only
be designed to hurt and kill people
being boots stop somewhere and in this
occasion stop Philly so it's a very
callous act as I said in January the
threat level of Northern Ireland has
been severe for a number of years that
remains extant it is still severe we
have seen attacks now here in the city
last July with shooting attack January
and is so unfortunately the threat is
present however the threat is not
dominant there is more peace in this
city than violence there is more
community placing than other placing and
there are more people in this city and
across Northern Ireland who do not want
this violence we know that will live
here we know that so it's important that
we all stand together and I unn resist
any further escalation of this police
did not return fire and certainly from
what you seeing on the on the footage it
appears to be a handgun but we did not
return fire
if a police didn't use any force at this
scene last night police were very
measured they absorb quite a bit of
violence they didn't engage in
confrontation with with these people all
the violence was directed at us
that's it I probably seen similar to
what you have seen of a gun man Christ
and firing down the road so I don't know
what's in his psyche all the new ways he
brought a weapon out in the street
unused it and the guns kill and that's
where we are this morning
I'm saying your officers
yes I mean it appears that she was tonic
Lucia please sound over and and then our
officers were alerted to the fact that
she was injured they reacted very
quickly and decided the quickest thing
to do was to put her in a Land Rover try
and assist her try and keep her alive
and get her out the Galvan hospital but
unfortunately that was all in vain
well the riding had been ongoing
obviously so I mean they just left scene
immediately with her and then the police
continued to told the whole thing that
we had I oughta stay and she is a
journalist but may understand II would
be that last night she wasn't actively
working as a journalist but that's a
matter for her and her family as to her
private business as to why she was here
in the city but to be honest why she was
here as irrelevant she should not be
dead you know there's no reason why this
person should have had this done to them
there's just no reason at all and but
she had her reasons for being they were
perfectly legitimate she's a perfectly
innocent bystander and we just have to
orderly condemn this